first can you give me an example of
something you accomplished in the nun
too that you know you have to credit to
doing La Llorona and The Conjuring 3
first where if the filmmaking order had
changed you wouldn't have been able to
accomplish that thing on this movie you
know I think the well the whole movie
honestly
um the I think the newsstand sequence
was probably the the biggest one that
was the you know the with the scares
you're always trying to come up with
something that's unique and memorable
and it was one of the earliest ideas
that I had as we first started
developing the movie and literally it
was the longest most hardest journey to
get that thing pulled off and
um it basically was like I was working
on that until the end it was like the
first thing I was working on and the
last thing I was working on
um that was 100 a beast and really uh
and and it almost broke me I didn't know
I didn't know it was one unseen could
break someone but it was uh it was a
beast oh so many follow-up questions
specifically for the uh the magazine
stand sequence what was it that took so
long is there a particular element of
crafting something like that that
requires that amount of time you know it
was everything even in how it would be
conceived you know I knew that um I got
it like I was looking at all this like
street photography from the uh France in
the 50s and there was I think it was
like Renee maltet probably got his name
wrong but he's uh French photographer
and he'd do this kind of like visual
like
kind of trickery with like his uh his
photos but they were kind of it was all
in camera and I just thought it would be
cool if like the nun was manifesting in
the environment and then I would see
these like these old newsstands and so I
I had this idea I was like I want the
nun to appear within a newsstand and I
was thinking maybe it's like a flip book
maybe it's like each magazine is like a
flip book and then it's a collage and
they're all kind of like you know coming
together
and and then I I I was like how we're
gonna do that I thought well we should
just do it all on camera should like
print all these magazines and then
mechanically rig them all to turn and um
and you know we blow some with wind and
then some of them are a little bit more
controlled and that got us like 50 of
the way there
but then it's like the some of the
mechanical rigging would break and we're
shooting at night and it was like the
whole thing was falling apart and it's
like this will never work and so then we
there was some like visual effects like
supplementing it in the end
um but uh it was it was really a beast I
mean just from like the you know how the
how it would manifest and because you
know
it's it was trickier than it looks I am
surprised even that much of that
sequence was done practically in camera
job very very well done with that part
what about in in a broader sense in
terms of visual Scare Tactics can you
maybe give me an example of you know a
trick you thought was really scary when
you first started making movies but
along the way with all of your
experience realized like actually if I
do it this way it's far more terrifying
I think that the
I think great scares are really patient
I think having like the confidence and
you know also
yeah I think great horror movies great
movies have a great relationship with
the audience I mean especially a great
horror movie and having
giving them room to breathe it's like
it's almost like a like a stand-up
comedian like a really good comedian a
really good someone who's like you know
really good on stage like it interacts
with the audience and it's hard to do
that it's hard to do that when you're
making your first movie because you're
like you don't know like what the
audience is thinking you're like you're
just there scrambling to make your day
you don't know you got kids that you're
gonna lose in like a couple minutes it's
like and I I what I've come to realize
is like that relationship with the
audience
giving them room to be engaged like they
come in an audience comes in with so
much energy they're excited to see the
movie they're they have their own fears
they're bringing their own fears into
these spaces and it's kind of like
giving them that space and giving them
the room to to like to lean in I think
that that's something that
um I've come to appreciate more in other
filmmakers I've I'm always striving for
more and it's just you know building
with that that relationship as a member
of that audience I appreciate that
answer quite a bit all right I gotta
talk about a Kayla Cooper because I
don't know how much the two of you work
directly together on the film but
clearly she's becoming one of the most
exciting voices in horror right now so
can you maybe specify something that she
brought to this story or maybe The
Conjuring verse overall that is unique
to her and wound up being especially
creatively fulfilling for you to execute
in the film
um there's two things one would be in
spoiler territory and then the other
ones wouldn't be would we like I could
come back to the put a pin in that we'll
come back to it we'll come back to the
akayla uh that one thing what she did
bring is the core story was all was
always there the the idea that um I
first of all I always loved the
characters of Irene and uh and Jonas
um Maurice played by Jonas
um from the first film I love their like
their relationship a little bit of their
flirtation I love how he was a little
bit of a dog and and you know she was
you know none in training and and there
was that kind of chemistry there and
that that friendship and you know in the
first film you know he saves her life
and there's that life debt there
and the core emotional through line of
this of her script which like really
stayed through the end is the the idea
of this life debt the idea that
um
she uh she owed him and you know now
that he was the one who needed saving
and she goes on this Mission and she's
facing her fear she's going back into
into hell on this journey to to save her
friend and the the idea that I was like
I was that was so emotionally powerful I
was like I love that I love these
characters I also love the actors so
much like they're so great and I just
thought that this is so really
compelling that's the first thing she
brought the other thing is the sister
Deborah I love how it was it had you
know there's a lot of these kind of
great just reversals in the in the film
where in the first the first film Irene
is the the junior recruit she's you know
being brought in for her special powers
by you know the the older priest and
then and this one she's the senior
member she's like the top dog and she's
like not recruiting but you know you
have a young novice yet who's who's
tagging along with her and I thought the
role reversal there was so fun and and I
really I really you know gravitated that
I though those core elements right off
the bat I think she has great a great
sense of story and she also loves horror
movies I think we just geeked out about
that all the time we're big like Ridley
Scott fans we're big um alien fans and
uh you know she uh there's like yeah
there's lots of like even like nods in
that that some of them I don't know if
it meant made into the Final Cut but
there's like you know she has like
Ridley Scott
Easter eggs in the movie oh I am so
curious now to give it a re-watch and
try to find some of them before we
switch to spoiler territory I'll squeeze
in two more questions here because you
brought up Jonas I'll go specifically to
him can you kind of walk us through
maybe some of the conversations you had
or some of the notes you gave him when
it came to figuring out how much of him
was like OG Frenchy and how much of him
was Valic
um you know that was always uh
it was always a discussion I think one
of the big things is we wanted him to be
um
he's the relationship that he's having
with everyone at the the school is needs
to be Frenchy it needs to be we need to
establish someone that we love and is
worth saving that's one of the tricks of
the movie and a little bit of a magic
trick in the uh or rule bending is you
know he needs to have a relationship
with Sophie with with uh our young girl
he needs to have a relationship with
Kate the teacher and and you need to
believe in these relationships and care
about them
um even though we come to realize that
that valak is within him using him as a
vessel so um that needed to be the true
OG Frenchie and it couldn't be some
valak manipulation because I think if
you thought that valik was just becoming
friends with Sophie to manipulate a
situation then everything was kind of
thrown out the window so it it needed
that needed to be valid and you needed
to feel like that was a relationship
that was worth fighting for he had
another win in that respect I love that
character so so much I will ask this is
not spoiled territory because it is
mentioned in the First Act of the movie
but bringing up you know Frenchie going
from film one to two there is one
character that didn't make it from film
one to two and it was making me wonder
was there ever a version of this movie
where you all brought back father Burke
as a zombie yes
um but I would watch that
you're joking but I'm serious I want to
see that now
I mean that was an idea that was you
know what I thought it was it was a
legitimate idea I I I I I pitch a lot of
crazy ideas
I mean it was one of those things
because you're like and you know it was
one of many ideas so it's like it's not
uh I I don't know how how far it was uh
I even like I think I probably killed it
while I was still in the crib but the um
you know at the end of the movie you
want to like you want it to be a fun
house of scares and you want valak to be
throwing everything it has at our
characters
um so that was in consideration but I
don't know if we could have brought back
uh the father Burke just just to be a
zombie but um yeah you know it was
something we were you know there was so
many great characters out of the first
film
um
you we you know it was something we like
I think we really wanted to introduce
storm we I think that we wanted to
introduce another nun and so it became a
balance of how big does this team get
how many story lines can we carry and um
you know father Burke unfortunately
um well you'll see the film